karate is a way of communicating ask me
a question
what are your plans for the weekend I'm
going to do some grocery shopping then
rent a film to watch in the comfort of
my own
oh that answer your question
I want you to tell me why you're here
I'm afraid I'm afraid of the dark I'm
afraid of other men I want to be what
intimidates me you came to the right
place I'm taking my first class today
your new white belts is that the first
belt color white is before color you
haven't earned color yet today's lesson
to kick with your fists and punch with
your feet that makes perfect sense
good there's a mental component as well
everything should be as masculine as
possible
you may want to start on those reports
that pile is getting awfully high oh I
won't be petting you anymore this is for
your own good
what's your favorite style of music
adult contemporary no should be metal
you're a blade and I'm sharpening you I
see a little myself in you thank you
says it why are you filming this this
isn't a safe place Casey I know you're
confused about what's happening
you have to trust me I should have never
started taking karate you can't be weak
anymore I'm interested in buying a gun I
need something I can fit into my hand
sounds like you're after a handgun
[Music]
I challenge you to a fight to the death
and unarmed combat this is your belt it
is yours and it's sacred there'll be a
sixteen dollar charge to replace a lost
now
you